let us pray together the general God who
has been our helper in times past
continue to be our help in these days
more than two centuries you have blessed
our nation but dedicated in selfless
soldiers in uniform stand ready to
deploy and defend our nation's freedoms
as we honor captain will Swenson for his
actions during the battle with John
jiggle we honor the sacred trust that he
and his team embodied that day we thank
you for the last full measure of
devotion given that day the Medal of
Honor is draped around captain Swenson
may the healing grace of hope and peace
rest upon each of us the captain swenson
example rekindle in us a spirit of
sacrifice and a steadfastness of purpose
but this occasion renew our commitment
to uphold the right to oppose the wrong
and continue to work that has begun so
long ago this we ask in praying their
Holy Name Amen
good afternoon everybody please have a
seat
on behalf of Michelle and myself welcome
to the White House last month the United
States Army released a remarkable piece
of video it's from the combat helmet
cameras of a medevac helicopter crew in
Afghanistan and it's shaky and it's
grainy but it takes us to the frontlines
that our troops face every single day
and it's useful to remember that there's
still a whole lot of our troops in
Afghanistan in harm's way in that video
as that helicopter touches down by a
remote village you see out of a cloud of
dust an American soldier he's without
his helmet standing in the open exposing
himself to enemy fire standing watch
over a severely wounded soldier he helps
carry that wounded soldier to the
helicopter and places him inside and
then emits the whipping wind and the
deafening roar of the helicopter blades
he does something unexpected he leans in
and kisses the wounded soldier on the
head a simple act of compassion and
loyalty to a brother in arms and as the
door closes and the helicopter takes off
he turns and goes back the way he came
back into the heat of battle you know in
our nation's history we have presented
our highest military decoration the
Medal of Honor nearly 3,500 times for
actions above and beyond the call of
duty but this may be the first time that
we can actually bear witness to a small
fraction of those actions for ourselves
and today we honor the American in that
video the soldier who went back in
Captain William Swenson not far away
that day was then corporal Dakota Meyer
to whom we presented the Medal of Honor
two years ago today is only the second
time in nearly half a century that the
Medal of Honor has been awarded to two
survivors of the same battle
Dakotah is not here today but I wanted
to welcome some of the soldiers and
Marines who fought alongside both these
men and the families of those who gave
their lives that day I want to welcome
all of our distinguished guests
including members of the Medal of Honor
Society whose ranks today grow by one
more most of all I want to welcome wills
wonderful parents Julian and Carolyn
Wells girlfriend Kelsey had a chance to
visit with them both Carl and Julia are
former college professors so instead of
a house full of GI Joes we'll grow up in
Seattle surrounded by educational games
I'm told that even when low Will was
little his mom was always a stickler for
grammar always making sure he said to
whom instead of to who so I'm going to
be very careful today I just had a
chance to spend some time with him and I
have to say will is a pretty low-key guy
his idea of a good time isn't a big
ceremony like this one he'd rather be
somewhere up in the mountains or on a
trail surrounded by cedar trees instead
of cameras but I think our nation needs
this ceremony today a moments like this
Americans like will remind us of what
our country can be at its best a nation
of citizens who look out for one another
who meet our obligations to one another
not just when it's easy but also when
it's hard maybe especially when it's
hard well you're an example to everyone
in this city and to our whole country of
the professionalism and patriotism that
we should strive for whether we wear
uniform or not not just on particular
occasions but all the time you know for
those who aren't familiar with the story
of the battle that led will to be here
today I want to take you back to that
September morning four years ago it's
around sunrise a column of Afghans
soldiers and their American advisers are
winding their way up a narrow trail
towards a village to meet with elders
but just as the first soldier reaches
the outskirts of the village all hell
breaks loose almost instantly for
Americans three Marines one Navy at the
front of the column are surrounded will
and the soldiers in the center of the
column are pinned down rocket-propelled
grenades mortar machine-gun fire all of
this is pouring in from three sides as
he returns fire will calls for air
support but his initial requests are
denied will and his team are too close
to the village and then will learns that
his noncommissioned officer sergeant
first class Kenneth Westbrook has been
shot in the neck so will breaks across
50 metres of open space bullets biting
all around lying on his back he presses
a bandage to Kenneth's wounds with one
hand and calls for a medevac with the
other trying to keep his buddy calm by
this time the enemy has gotten even
closer just twenty or thirty meters away
and over the radio they're demanding the
Americans to surrender so will stops
treating Kenneth long enough to respond
by lobbying a grenade and finally after
more than an hour and a half of fighting
air support arrives will directs them to
nearby targets then it's time to move so
exposing himself again to enemy fire
will help scary Kenneth the length of
more than two football fields down steep
terraces to that helicopter and then in
the moment captured by those cameras
will leans in to say goodbye
but more Americans and more Afghans are
still out there so will does something
incredible he jumps behind the wheel of
an unarmed Ford Ranger pickup truck a
Marine gets in the passenger seat and
they drive that truck as a vehicle
design for the highway straight into the
battle twice they pick up injured Afghan
soldiers bullets whizzing past them
slamming into the pickup truck twice
they bring them back when the truck
gives out they grab a Humvee the marine
by will side has no idea how they
survived but he says by that time it
didn't matter we weren't going to leave
any soldiers behind
finally a helicopter spots those four
missing Americans hours after they were
trapped in the open ambush so will gets
in another Humvee with a crew that
includes Dakota Meyer and together they
drive past enemy fighters up through the
valley exposed once more and when they
reach the village will jumps out drawing
even more fire dodging even more bullets
but they reach those Americans lying
where they fell well and the others
carry them out one by one they bring
their fallen brothers home scripture
tells us the greatest among you shall be
your servant captain will Swenson was a
leader on that September morning but
like all great leaders he was also a
servant to the men he commanded to the
more than a dozen Afghans and Americans
whose lives he saved to the families of
those who gave their last full measure
of devotion on that faraway field as one
of his fellow soldiers later said will
did things that nobody else would ever
do and he did it for his guys and for
everybody on the ground to get them out
and that's why after I called will to
tell him he'd be receiving this medal
one of the first things he did was to
invite to this ceremony those who fought
alongside him and I'd like all of those
who served with such valor alongside
we'll both Army and Marines who fought
for each other please stand and be
recognized
thank you we'll also reached out to the
families of the four Americans who gave
their lives that day to them he wrote
and I'm quoting will now we have never
met we have never spoken but I would
like to believe that I know something
about each of you through the actions of
your loved ones on that day they were
part of a team and you are now part of
that team so I would ask the members of
this team of the families of first
lieutenant Michael Johnson gunnery
sergeant Edward Johnson
gunnery sergeant Aaron kenefick and
hospital 'men third class James Layton
as well as the family of Kenneth
Westbrook to please stay
Kenneth was the soldier will delivered
to the safety of that helicopter and
after being airlifted out he made it to
Walter Reed he started rehab and spent
time with his wife Charlene who joins us
here today she still remembers the first
time she spoke to will when he called
from Afghanistan to check in on Kenneth
soon after that phone call however
Kenneth took a turn for the worse he
succumbed to complications from his
treatment but I think it's fair to say
that Charlene will always be grateful
for the final day she was able to spend
with her husband and even now a month
rarely goes by when will doesn't call
her taks checking in with Charlene and
her three boys that's the kind of man he
is Charlene says about well you don't
have to ask Wolfe for help he just knows
when to be there for you so well Swenson
was there for his brothers he was there
for their families as a nation we thank
God the Patriots like him are there for
us all so well god bless you and all the
men that you fought alongside and
everything that you've done for us god
bless all our men and women in uniform
and god bless the United States of
America with that I'd like my military
to read the citation please
the President of the United States of
America authorized by act of Congress
March 3rd 1863 has awarded in the name
of Congress the Medal of Honor to
captain William de Swenson United States
Army for conspicuous gallantry and
intrepidity at the risk of his life
above and beyond the call of duty
Captain William D Swanson distinguished
himself by acts of gallantry and
intrepidity at the risk of his life
above and beyond the call of duty while
serving as embedded advisor to the
Afghan national board of police task
force Phoenix combined security
transition command Afghanistan and
support of 1st battalion 32nd Infantry
Regiment 3rd Brigade Combat Team 10th
Mountain Division during combat
operations against an armed enemy in
Kunar province Afghanistan on September
8 2009 on that morning more than 60
well-armed well-positioned enemy
fighters ambushed captain Swanson's
combat team as it moved on foot into the
village of Ganjgal for a meeting with
village elders as the enemy unleashed a
barrage a rocket-propelled grenade
mortar and machine gun fire captain
Swanson immediately returned fire and
coordinated and directed the response of
his Afghan border police while
simultaneously calling in suppressive
artillery fire and aviation support
after the enemy effectively flanked
coalition forces captain Swenson
repeatedly called for smoke to cover the
withdrawal of the forward elements
surrounded on three sides by enemy
forces inflicting effective and accurate
fire captain Swenson coordinated air
assets indirect fire support and medical
evacuation helicopter support to allow
for the evacuation of the wounded
captain Swanson ignored enemy radio
transmissions demanding surrender and
maneuvered uncovered to render medical
aid to a wounded fellow soldier captain
Swanson stopped administering aid long
enough to throw a grenade at approaching
enemy forces before assisting with
moving the soldier for air evacuation
with complete disregard for his own
safety captain Swenson unhesitatingly
led a team in an unarmed vehicle into
the kill zone
exposing himself to enemy fire on at
least two occasions to recover the
wounded and search for for missing
comrades
after using aviation support to mark
locations of fallen and unit comrades it
became clear that ground recovery of the
fawn was required due to heavy enemy
fire on helicopter landing zones
captain Swanson's team returned to the
kill zone another time in a Humvee
captain Swanson voluntarily exited the
vehicle exposing himself to enemy fire
to locate and recover three fallen
Marines and one fallen Navy corpsman his
exceptional leadership and stout
resistance against the enemy during six
hours of continuous fighting rallied his
teammates and effectively disrupted the
enemy's a soul captain william de
Swanson's extraordinary heroism and
selflessness above and beyond the call
of duty are in keeping with the highest
traditions of military service and
reflect great credit upon himself Task
Force Phoenix 1st battalion 32nd
infantry regiment 3rd Brigade Combat
Team 10th Mountain Division and the
United States Army
let us pray
colonel god we ask your blessing to rest
upon AUSA this day we go forth in peace
inspired by the actions of courageous
and good people they we follow the
example set by captain Swenson and his
team via people of valor ready when the
cause for which we have given our bow
bow confronts us going to strength to
live through troubled times fill us with
grace equal to every need and grant us
the wisdom and the will to do justice to
love mercy and to walk humbly this we
ask and pray in your Holy Name Amen
well let me say once again not only to
will but all our men and women in
uniform who have served us with such
incredible courage and professionalism
that America is grateful for you to the
families of those we've lost we will
never forget and will you are a
remarkable role model for all of us and
we're very grateful for your service
we are going to have a reception after
this I hear the food's pretty good
around here and so I hope all you have a
chance to stay and those of you who have
a chance to say thank you to will
personally obviously that's very welcome
I'm going to be exiting with will and
Michelle first we'll take a couple of
pictures but enjoy yourselves this
afternoon god bless america
you